It's beautiful
isn't it
we have watched
and guided we have helped them progress
and seen them accomplish wonders
throughout the years we have never interfered
until now
thank you for this oh you're welcome. So now that
captain rogers and iron man are both gone
who do you think's gonna lead
the avengers could lead them
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my brand
new marvel eternals trailer video we finally have
an actual full trailer there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs obviously they reference avengers
end game iron man captain america so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
getting ready for marvel loki episodes i'll
be doing videos for all those and we're doing
a disney plus giveaway too all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the video
but if you couldn't tell the song that they
use in this trailer is the end of the world
by skeeter davis very apropos because it's a
reference to both avengers end game which they
directly call out at the end of the trailer
in a reference to the plot of the movie
because the earth is threatened with imminent
destruction a couple different times across
history multiple times the biggest being that
giant storm cloud that they're all looking at
at the end of the trailer which is meant
to signify the celestial host coming
like a celestial threatening to destroy the earth
the same way you saw issan the searcher using the
power stone to destroy an entire world in that
first guardians of the galaxy movie the events of
the movie pick up right after avengers end game so
everyone posts all the memes oh here we go again
but i will chart the timeline as they jump around
in time during the trailer because you see them
at several different points in human history
going back tens of thousands of years but as
the song starts playing were meant to be tens of
thousands of years ago at the dawn of civilization
when people were just starting to transition from
the hunter-gatherer existence to living in towns
learning to farm what you're seeing here is the
eternals rolling up in their spaceship to ancient
mesopotamia the cradle of real world civilization
in a spaceship to begin their watch so to speak
post all your game of thrones jokes because we
have kit harrington jon snow and richard madden
rob stark in the movie next time i see you you'll
be dressed all in black and kit harrington is
playing dane whitman the black knight during this
movie since i'm going through the trailer shot by
shot i'll talk more about what's going on with his
character when we get to that part of the trailer
but make all the night's watch references too
because now their watch begins as their spaceship
literally rolls up so that they can watch over
humanity time to take the black the eternal's
backstory in the movie is going to be a little
bit different from what it is in the comics so
in the movie the celestials are still responsible
for creating the eternals but the reason why they
create them is a little bit different in the
circumstances around their creation is a little
bit different in the original jack kirby comics
the celestials showed to planet earth and they
began experimenting with humans giving them powers
with celestial energy modifying them turning them
into the eternals in the deviants the difference
in the movie is that they actually create them
separately and then the eternals come to planet
earth based on descriptions of the movie now
the celestials are still going around sort of
experimenting with life all over the universe
like you see during the original guardians of
the galaxy movie but supposedly they create the
deviance first to watch over life protect the
life that they're experimenting on all over the
universe but supposedly eventually the deviants
start to hunt down the very life that they're
supposed to protect you sort of see a fight later
in the trailer that's happening in present day
where kingo and thena are both fighting one of the
deviants like this giant animal looking creature
with all the celestial energy arcing all over
its body and supposedly at least based on the
descriptions the celestials send the eternals to
planet earth to stop the deviants from killing
all the humans off and sort of watch over a
celestial egg that's growing inside the earth
like the celestials are trying to create another
celestial and they're using the earth to incubate
that growing celestial so also the secret mission
that the eternals are there for is to watch over
the celestial that's growing and developing over
the tens of thousands of years until it eventually
hatches grows and comes out threatening to destroy
the earth again like the song in the trailer
says it's the end of the world but as the trailer
implies eventually the eternals begin to think of
humans as their children so to speak they begin to
love them like they're part of their family like
they themselves are a family so there's all these
themes about them helping humans guiding them not
really interfering but then finally interfering
because it is the end of the world that's also
a bit of a reference to them not interfering
with avengers end game i'll explain that in
a second too because everyone's like where were
they when thanos was attacking and snapping the
infinity gauntlet sure could have used some of
those celestial powers that they have but you
notice their ship their costumes are covered in
those cosmic symbols they're the same symbols
that you see all over the celestial's bodies you
see the symbols rise up when they're using their
powers as well it's kind of marvel trying to do a
real world looking example a live-action looking
example of the classic kirby crackle which was
jack kirby's way of depicting cosmic energy they
actually did the kirby crackle for real like the
actual kirby version of it during spider-man into
the spider-verse all of them share some of the
same abilities in common like enhanced durability
strength and incredibly long lifespans they're
functionally immortal they live longer than
asgardians they all have some unique abilities
too you see most of them during the trailer so
i'll point them out when we see them but they
set up the relationship between sersi and ikaris
and it's also funny to see jon snow rob stark in
another character named sersi in a movie her name
is based on sersi from greek mythology so a lot
of the humans over the years worship them as gods
and they inspire a lot of the gods that you see in
different religions around earth and human history
but there's meant to be a love triangle between
her character ikaris and kit harrington's black
knight character in present day the interesting
thing about the black knight character is it is
actually a title that's passed down through dane
whitman's lineage so the black knight comes from
medieval mythology like the original black knight
and then his family is cursed you have the ebony
blade and his suit of armor that gets passed out
it's the blade that's important the blade carries
the curse but in present day dane whitman becomes
the latest black knight so he takes up the title
it's just that he doesn't really learn about it
until present day like you see the dumbfounded
look on his face don't worry we'll talk about him
in a second this is a nice shot of the interior
of their craft you notice that it's actually from
present day though already big time jump because
this is meant to be salma hayek's ajak character
wearing a cowboy hat which they definitely did
not have in 10000 bc here's a version of her
in her full costume notice she has a different
headpiece notice all the designs behind her
too on that mural and some of the artifacts
they have depictions of all the animals of earth
you see some artifacts around this room there are
a couple shots later in the trailer where you get
a better look at this so i'll talk about that as
we sort of go through the trailer footage ajak is
meant to be one of the leaders amongst their group
ikarisis technically their leader in the comics
one of the main characters and you kind of see him
present himself that way like later in the trailer
where he's like i could lead the avengers but
amongst the eternals ajak acts as sort of like a
big sister to the others later in the trailer you
see all that footage of the aztec city eventually
the aztecs worship her as their god quetzalcoatl
this is angelina jolie's thena character obviously
based on the greek god athena goddess of the hunt
then in another scene in the same room you get
a better look at it you see brian tyree henry's
phastos character that sprite behind him on the
table phastos was worshipped as the greek god
hephaestus his name inspired the name hephaestus
is a bit of the same situation with the other
eternal's characters but as the name implies
he makes things like the greek god hephaestus
in the comics at least he carries a hammer-like
weapon that fires lightning bolts you can make
all the references to thor wielding mjolnir his
hammer that shoots lightning bolts even though
technically it's thor that shoots lightning
bolts as he uses his powers to start making
something you see all the cosmic symbols the
celestial symbols start emanating with energy
like i said it's the same for all the eternals
even though some of their powers are different
when they use their powers you see the celestial
energy patterns sort of emanate from them but they
have this really cool transition to the marvel
studios logo as the celestial symbols sort of
spread out filling the frame marvel's been getting
really creative with their newer intros in marvel
phase four then later you see what seems like the
eternals and sersi teaching humans how to farm so
that they can start living together in towns and
eventually form cities you see her changing the
dirt into water helping nourish the crops one of
her special powers is transmutation she can change
anything into anything else she can also create
perfect illusions too which you kind of see later
in the trailer i'll talk about but then they
started with sama hayek's voice over as ajak
when she's giving this speech she's talking to
the other eternals characters and they use it
in a montage chronicling their history on earth
she talks about how they watched over and guided
humanity and helped them progress technologically
then you see sersi's hand with her green sleeve
here in the costume handing a dagger with their
cosmic symbols on it like an eternals dagger to
one of the early humans because the clothing
here in this scene is the same as when their
ship is rolling up to mesopotamia in these early
humans here i think it's probably them introducing
themselves to humans for the first time this
is angelina jolie's thena character seemingly
she's helping train these city guards later
in the timeline in mesopotamia like in this
larger city many years later then everyone bows
down in a separate scene in this same town maybe
from some other part of the movie worshiping
them as gods then ajak says they've seen them
accomplish wonders the trailer jumps forward in
the timeline again to ancient babylon but it's the
eternals having their own avengers assemble kind
of moment getting ready for a battle based on all
this destruction like there's some big fight that
they're in the middle of this is makkari on the
left that you're seeing for the first time she has
super speed powers like the flash as you can see
fina on her right this is gilgamesh next to her
he has crazy super strength in the comics way
beyond the other eternals he's kind of like their
version of the hulk only he doesn't change form as
his name implies that ancient sumerian poem the
epic of gilgamesh is meant to be based on him
this is ikaris next to him and then this is the
first scene with kumail nanjiani's kingo character
his powers might be a little bit different in the
movie but he's mostly known as one of the greatest
swordsmen on the planet he's often depicted as
fighting with two katanas in the comics this is
makkari sitting inside their spaceship inside that
same room that we saw before with phastos reading
from a pile of books that they've accumulated over
the centuries and you see artifacts from all over
the world all over human history in the timeline
from ancient europe the suit of armor crowns
things from ancient egypt ancient rome paintings
from much more recently in history and some of
these books are from modern day just meant to show
you their continued influence over the years on
humanity as they've developed makari is meant
to be the inspiration for the roman god mercury
in the greek god hermes but as you can see from
later in the trailer they were around and amongst
humans before the events of avengers infinity
war like they knew who the avengers were they'd
been watching the news in modern day before thanos
snap then this scene is actually deceptive because
this is sersi walking through that same ancient
babylon city amongst all the people but notice
how she's wearing a modern day flannel shirt and
then they transition to the present day london
is because she was using her powers to create a
perfect illusion of the city based on her memories
then ajak voiceover talks about how they've never
interfered over the years despite all the terrible
things that have happened to humans then they
show you some terrible things happening to humans
across the years like this is what seems like a
bunch of the conquistadors slaughtering the aztec
natives ajak hugging phastos they're all wearing
modern day clothing so maybe this is after the
events of avengers end game after they have their
reunion and they sort of remember everything but
you see ikaris and a bunch of them in this small
village but it's in present day because kingo is
wearing modern day clothes and there's a camera
crew behind him you see druid for the first time
he's kind of one of the black sheep of the family
so to speak kind of a rogue kind of like loki you
see druid using his powers he can also transmute
matter has telekinesis he can fly he could project
energy he has a limited form of telepathy as
well that you see later in the trailer this kind
of like scarlet witch's telepathy you see thena in
the middle of a fight with her big energy blade in
that same small village that they keep going back
to this seems like a wedding that they're in the
middle of or a big celebration in india and then
later in present day after they got their memories
back funny that jon snow and rob stark will have a
love triangle with a character named sersi this is
another scene of sersi using her powers to change
this structure into water notice the celestial
energy symbols all around it as she's using her
abilities this is kingo in the middle of making
a bollywood movie in present day or at least in
modern day before the snap before avengers end
game kingo becomes a bollywood star but then he's
using his abilities in that same small village
that drug was in in present day to defend the
people against one of these deviants this is the
scene of druid using his powers of telepathy to
make everyone raise their weapons up the regular
humans like i said it's a bit like scarlet witch
using her telepathy on the sword agents during
wandavision this scene of the volcano exploding
might be from early history it's kind of hard
to tell based on the landscape but the theme of
the trailer is that the world is ending again
so i think this is meant to highlight that like
oh the earth is being threatened many times
throughout history this is sprite in some of the
other eternals on kingo's private plane in present
day notice the k on the door in the background
remember he's a bollywood star so he would be rich
this is sersi with kit harrington's dane whitman
character in present day it seems like she's just
teaching him about the history of the eternals
because he's just completely dumbfounded what
is this sorcery these storm clouds that they're
watching seem like they're meant to signify the
coming of the celestial host or a coming of a
celestial usually they wind up being the main
antagonist in any big eternal story like the
deviants sound like they're the villains but
really the celestials are the villains threatening
to obliterate the earth then this is the full wide
shot of all the eternals introducing themselves
to humans for the first time like i said they keep
going back to the same scene of them introducing
themselves for the very first time then they have
the tag scene of them sharing a meal on present
day after the events of avengers end game after
it seems like they've gotten all their memories
back and had a reunion and sprite asks who do
you think is going to lead the avengers now
that captain america and iron man are gone
notice how she says they're both gone not dead
which i think is funny i mean post all your
theories about that iron man is supposed to be
dead they're supposed to have burned the body and
scattered his ashes across the lake next to his
house but there were all the theories on falcon
and winter soldier that people had about captain
america secretly being on the moon so i just feel
like that's a funny reference to that them being
gone but technically not dead but ikaris says i
could do it and he's actually being serious like i
could actually go lead the avengers and the other
just laugh at him like yeah right but that's also
meant to be a reference to the eternals eventually
crossing over with the avengers in the next
avengers movie like avengers 5 crossing over with
the other marvel cinematic universe characters
like thor spider-man doctor strange so it's
like them using this trailer to introduce these
really weird characters from these really cool
really weird jack kirby comics they're not mutants
but they're just like the next step on the path to
introducing x-men in the mcu full-blown mutants
like scarlet witch's children billy and tommy
technically they're mutants because they were
born with their powers so the whole idea with
why they didn't help during avengers end game is
that at least in the eternal's comic book that
this is based on the neil gaiman comic book one
of sprite's special powers is altering people's
memories so in that neil gaiman comic book
she makes all the other eternals characters
forget that they're eternal so they forget
that they have powers they forget who they are
and they just go about their lives living like
normal humans so that's the theory why they didn't
help out during avengers infinity war in avengers
endgame but eventually they start getting their
memories back and the story spins up into this big
celestial plot also be interested to see if any of
them actually got snapped during avengers infinity
war we'll find out about that pretty soon i'm sure
and we'll probably get more footage with kit
harrington's dane whitman character because
he is very important for the plot but i think
they wanted to use this first big trailer just
to introduce you to the concept of the characters
for people who have never read about the eternals
in the comics but hopefully that explains what's
going on during the eternals movie and hopefully
there'll be some references to thanos as well
because thanos is an eternal but he's an eternal
that was born on titan from a different group of
eternals but everyone let me know in the comments
what's your favorite part of the trailer and
i will do more eternals videos as we get more
footage and learn more details about the film
but like i said we have loki episodes that
are coming up real soon so everyone click here
for that brand new loki trailer in easter eggs
and click here for my brand new venom 2 let there
be carnage trailer with spider-man easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!